[Musique]
il
alors ce soir moi je viens avec une
question que signifie le made in mali
quand on dit médine mali on penserait
tout de suite à nos ressources comme
l'or comme le coton à notre savoir faire
qui nous a donné le beau rôle en que
chris et doux a fait connaître un
partout dans le monde à l'autre peinture
qui je dirais à terme peut pas ne pas se
sentir coupable parce que si le bazin
est ce qu'il est aujourd'hui c'est grâce
au savoir faire de la peinture malienne
[Applaudissements]
donc pour moi le made in mali et
représentent toutes ces choses qui sont
le bon rôle en partie ses bases 1 mais
le made in mali représente quelque chose
de beaucoup plus importante pour moi
j'entends par là que j'ai envie de
partager avec vous c'est ce médine mali
en ces points
le premier c'est non malien j'estime que
non on doit se considérer comme les
ressources du mali en terme de matière
grise et de main d'oeuvre
il est temps aujourd'hui qu'on prenne
conscience de notre potentiel
il est temps qu'on comprenne qu'on est
capable de faire de créer des choses par
nous mêmes avec les choses de chez nous
pour nous mais aussi pour le monde
entier
mais pour cela il faut déjà qu'on
prenne la responsabilité et la
conscience de le voir en deuxième point
le made in mali pour moi c'est
l'opportunité
j'entends par opportunité que notre
génération est dans un pays où tout est
à faire
donc c'est une chance pour nous de faire
partie de ces personnes qui seront
acteurs du développement de ce pays
j'estime que c'est une chance parce que
dans notre pays on va dire ils en sont
loin
on va les inquiet pour des raisons x
pour des raisons y
mais pour nous j'estime que le fait de
pouvoir se réaliser et de participer au
développement de notre pays
il n'y a pas quelque chose de plus
profond
j'aimerais partager mon médigue mali
avec vous sur le troisième point pour
moi qui ait l'idée parce qu' il ne
serait rien sans l'idée est l'idée c'est
cette petite chose qu'on a tous chacun
grâce à son parcours ses 28 à 1 station
à sa culture à son environnement si on
prend la décision de s'écouter de
chercher à se connaître pour trouver
cette chose là qu'on peut apporter
donc pour moi quand l'idée est là
le made in mali représente le fait de
partir de peu parce qu'on est dans un
pays pauvre
bien sûr manque d'infrastructures en
manque de plein de choses mais à partir
du moment où on a une idée le plus
important pour moi c'est de faire le pas
c'est de faire ce qu'on peut faire avec
ce qu'on a au mois sur le coup peut-être
que le reste suivra
mais c'est très important de d'essayer
de poser tous les jours un acte qui nous
avance un petit peu vers ce qu'on veut
faire ça cette idée m'est venue un jour
quand je regardais une interview de will
smith qui disait quand on veut un mur
parfait on commence tout d'abord par
poser une brique et ainsi de suite
on a un super but he et ça m'a donné
envie un jour de partager ça avec un
jeune qui était venu me voir il me
expliqué qu' il a un projet de créer un
magazine il m'expliquait que voilà tous
ces problèmes que nous tous mal à tous
les jeunes à lire pour phase
c'est-à-dire des problèmes de
financement des problèmes de facto voilà
donc je lui ai demandé mais où est ce
que tu en est avec ce projet là il me
dit je sais exactement ce que je veux je
sais ce que je vais mettre dans mon
premier numéro
je sais tout ce que je veux faire mais
malheureusement même pour faire mon
premier numéro
l'impression
beaucoup trop cher donc ce jour j'ai lu
expliquer un peu ça et je lui dis tu
sais ce que tu devrais faire si tu as
exactement une idée de ce que tu as
envie de faire de ce magazine là si tu
sais exactement le contenu va imprimer
toutes les photos que tu as envie de
voir dans un magazine va à la boutique
achète un cahier à 500 francs vient
coller des photos sur ton cahier et
rédige toutes les articles manuscrits et
tu auras ton premier numéro
je lui ai même dit en plaisantant que
peut-être qu'ici ça devient un magazine
un succès un jour ça vaudra des millions
de vendre son petit cahier qui serait le
numéro 02 de son projet donc pour moi le
made in mali
c'est aussi le fait de partir de peu et
par la suite mon point suivant ça serait
de persévérer parce que bien sûr on le
sait on est dans un pays où on fait face
à à des limitations dans tellement de
domaines mais je crois au fait que ces
limitations justement c'est pour nous
rendre ingénieux c'est pour qu'on puisse
trouver les moyens de les repousser ou
de les contourner
peu importe c'est de faire quelque chose
pour aller de l'avant pour aller un acte
qui nous avons très vers notre put donc
quand on persévère
pour moi il ya une chose qui est très
importante c'est le fait d'être dans la
recherche de proposer de
la réalité malheureusement je pense que
déjà un
les maliens même sont les premiers à
mépriser le made in mali à ne pas le
voir aussi bien on va dire mais au final
moi ce que je pense c'est que ce n'est
pas certaines personnes me disent que ya
certainement il ya certains maliens qui
ont honte des produits maliens c'est en
train de changer bien sûr mais il ya
cinq ans c'était pas comme ça mais pour
moi les gens n'ont pas à acheter du
local à acheter du made in mali parce
que c'est le média mali ce made in mali
doit correspondre à un besoin que de ça
soit de qualité ou plein d'autres points
ils doivent venir acheter ce made in
mali parce que ça repose à leurs besoins
donc au made in mali au local de
s'adapter en termes de qualité en termes
d'accessibilité et de faire en sorte que
son produit soit à la hauteur de la
demande ou des besoins de sa clientèle
cible
donc comme je finis avec ce point là
j'en viens au point que au final le made
in mali c'est vous parce que tous les
points que je viens de chacun d'entre
nous un moment de notre vie a dû vivre
l'expérience d'au moins un de ces points
là et j'ai envie de vous dire que le
point la chose qui m'amène ici
c'est que moi déjà je me sens mais dean
mali parce que tout six points que je
viens de citer
j'ai fait l'expérience en tant que
malien de tous ces points c'est ça qui
m'a amené à être la personne que je suis
aujourd'hui je suis madame sonami sa
terrasse j'ai je suis dit vis et j'ai
créé une marque de vêtements mais mali
il ya quelques années mon parcours
il est assez assez assez atypique parce
que je voulais être être médecin j'ai
commencé à l'école de médecine et les
circonstances de la vie ont fait que
j'ai changé de filière et après mes
études en marketing communication
je me suis retrouvé dans une agence de
com où je vais de l'événementiel mais
avec le temps il y avait cette petite
chose en moi qui qui qui qui étaient
attirés vers tout ce qui est ici chez
nous malgré que mon style était assez
dynamique et b à ses dires fonctionnel
mais je voulais quand même être dans
cette authenticité d'utiliser ce que je
peux trouver ici c'est qui est ici donc
c'est ça qui m'a fait comprendre
finalement le potentiel que les matières
premières ici peuvent être on va dire
moi ce que je j'imaginais que ya du
potentiel dans ces matières là et qu'au
final parce que tout ce que j'essayais
de de faire tout ce que je dessinais
j'avais des tailleurs qui arrivent et
âme les confectionner exactement comme
je l'imaginé donc je me suis dit on est
aussi capable de faire comme même si
c'est pas con mais on peut faire ce que
les autres grandes marques font donc
pourquoi est ce que les maltais donc
j'ai compris en fait que si ça n'existe
pas si j'en ai pris conscience
c'est peut-être que je peux le faire
donc je suis rentré dans la démarche de
comprendre déjà le secteur qui
m'attirait ensuite je me suis dit quel
meilleur moyen que de regarder tous ceux
qui ont prospéré la dent de lire leurs
cours de comprendre c'est qu'ils ont
essayé de faire de comprendre leur
philosophie pour enfin trouver moi ce
que j'ai envie finalement de proposer et
j'ai dû démissionner pour essayer de
comprendre tout ça pour être en
freelance
et en ce moment là a commencé on va dire
mon parcours mais dean mali parce que
j'ai dû faire face à énormément de
difficultés à partir de ce jour est la
première était la compréhension de ma
femme
face à ce choix là parce que on va dire
ce secteur étaient réduits on va dire
aux tailleurs du coin qui est là depuis
20 ans et dans les conditions sont
pareils
donc je peux comprendre que pour un
parent c'est difficile de voir son
enfant se projeter dans cette voie là et
qu'il ne va forcément pas trop et
ambitieux
je peux encore me rappeler de ce que ma
mère me disait
et pourtant tu es une fille intelligente
vraiment je ne comprends pas pourquoi
que tu partes toutes les journées devant
son ordinateur devant des feuilles avec
un pig au lieu d'aller chercher un vrai
travail en plus tu veux être un tailleur
je ne comprends pas mais aujourd'hui
heureusement elle est très fière de moi
du fait que je me suis entêté à à
continuer dans sa elle est fière et même
ce matin et elle m'a beaucoup encouragé
et ça m'a fait pleurer parce qu'il
aimait manger plein de doigts et je me
suis rappelé de ce que j'allais dire et
ça m'a beaucoup ému parce qu'aujourd'hui
elle est fière coin pas parce que j'en
suis arrivé au point où je veux mais
juste parce que j'ai pu lui prouver à
elle ainsi pas mes heures quand mon
entourage à l'époque ce que moi j'étais
seul à voir dans ma tête ce que j'étais
seul à croire aujourd'hui tout le monde
peut le voir parce que j'en suis
aujourd'hui on va dire un point où j'ai
fait une boutique qui est magnifique et
je reçois on va dire tellement de jeunes
maliens qui viennent nous voir et chaque
personne qui rentre dans ma boutique me
touche tellement parce que si je sais
pas comment je peux vous
vous le décrire ce sentiment que j'ai
quand quand on me dit en tout cas ça
c'était mon midi de ma vie et j'ai pu le
faire avec tout ce que j'ai eu à
traverser
je sais que n'importe qui peut le faire
alors aujourd'hui je vous invite à
prendre conscience de votre potentiel à
regarder le médine maliki est en tête et
je vous invite à réaliser ce médine mali
là parce que c'est pour s'organiser
soit en premier mais ça sert à quelque
chose qui est papa ou développement mali
je vous remercie
[Applaudissements]